[Music]
hey what's up
today we're going to
she
she got
it's outside of the emperor's temple
and right now there's a festival they
call it festival whenever i think of
festival i think of like a
concert it's supposed to be pretty
there'll be a bunch of lanterns we're
checking it out
[Music]
so that's the emperor's
[Music]
real estate
which is the most highest valued
land
i think in the world because it's so
expensive to build here and since it's
so central did i watch a tom scott video
or something i don't know where i landed
i would just build a bigger temple on
top like the one i have in minecraft
that's as if i was emperor
[Music]
sun went down we were supposed to catch
the sunset i may have taken a couple
just a couple few turns wrong but it's
supposed to be around here there's a lot
of people leaving
i hopefully you didn't miss it there's
stuff going on i think we're okay
i see lanterns over there kinda
let's go
it's very busy
but it's pretty oh look now you can see
it
that looks amazing
[Music]
my camera oh there we go
[Music]
i guess we caught it just in time way
busier than i thought i did meet the
sweetest fan though
it made me so happy he was from spain
he'd been trying to move here just like
i have for like the past three years so
this is kind of cool
we both shared the pain but now we both
made it we met each other that's kind of
yeah it's good
good times
and tired people stepped on me
my burrito part they hurt me look what
am i say preparing
that's good rice it always tastes better
when it's your cooking
i will say it is actually really hot
fine okay for an evening i do not expect
it to be the time
[Music]
i gotta be real with you japan
that ain't a sweden house what is that
that's not what swedish eyes look like
[Music]
um
damn
oh wow it goes all the way
this is spinning people
that's huge
damn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
which is like the fancy area there's so
many cool buildings it's super hot today
i didn't say it the government did okay
marseille came prepared they basically
warned to not go outside but we're doing
it anyway absolute mad lance it's like
39 which means it feels like 45 because
it's so humid this is cool
cool area
hey
i blend in
yo they got the pikachu camera
what a cool store
yes
oh that's nice
okay i like this
yes
oh i know where we are
there's that temple we're going to eat
basically
trying to find the place
oh
i do smell coriander then
look at this
you got a whole bento damn that looks
like a lot of food i forgot what it's
called but mine is cold for some hot
summer days and i got super spicy sauce
thank you
i can feel the top of my head
like cooking thank god i'm somewhat
blunt
jeez i mean i don't think it's hard or
anything
japan will not defeat me okay if we were
in sweden it was this hot people would
be crying everyone's acting like it's no
big deal wearing
black pants and black shirts
god damn
okay so maybe not perfect form
but i'm hitting pierce
and uh even though i'm cutting which is
[ __ ] great
amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm watching one piece
it's absolutely plastered everywhere
here in japan and i'm like how's that
possible how's it still going and i
finally gave it a watch and it's
actually really good i love watching it
every morning right maya
i always thought it was too kitty but it
it's kind of fun uh today we're actually
heading out we're going to roppongi and
checking out that area a little bit more
damn you got such a view of tokyo tower
and that's the
uh newest biggest
tallest building in tokyo i don't know
what it's called sorry
damn
so yeah here we are
i saw this when i was dropping off chris
and connor i was like i can't believe i
never seen it
it's the
seoul
georgie temple i think
wow
oh i forgot mercy
isn't she pretty
look at that
there's no one here too
wow
[Music]
it's just us
i love it
[Music]
this is where swan would be
oh my
shadow
yes
oh
[Music]
this is incredible
all right
let's see how it is
[Music]
i'm kind of
speechless this is insane we're here
early in the morning by the way it's
like 9 30. i don't know if you can hear
it but they're doing the
broadcast warning people that it's hot
and to make sure to drink a lot i don't
really think it's hot though
hello
i'm being cooked this is the best video
i've seen on tokyo tower
even though the
top is covered whatever just imagine
like
a string
i don't know what this feeling is
and like you're wet
that's weird you know we've been
visiting tokyo for years and years and
years
but there's still stuff you miss it's
kind of crazy i gotta pee so bad
and the toilet was closed because we're
here so early
how many paint so we're going here
wow
wow it keeps going
i have no clue what this is
[Music]
this is so cool
oh it keeps going no way
you're not allowed to enter here but
that is so amazing
wow
[Music]
okay i just read so these are
guardians for children
for their safety and for their growth
it's just nothing okay this is spf
what are you doing to me
i preheated the car because it's so
yeah i heated it
it's been blasting
oh
oh this is heaven that's what it is
that feels so good oh man
oh that means it feels like 47.
[Music]
we're going to uh
maury art again they have a different
exhibition now with yokai
which is like japanese spirits it looked
really cool plus it's inside
which i'm very happy about
i forgot about the view for a minute
damn
last time we went it was so cloudy
damn
oh what
look at this dude this is insane
damn
so this is tsunekosuri
and they're supposed to crawl on
people's legs when they're walking it's
supposed to be like a japanese spirit
whoa this is an actual spiritual
suddenly all these like final fantasy
games make sense because you see all the
weird oh my gosh
it means licking the ceiling i think in
a lot of wooden houses they have like
marks on the wood so it said that it's
left from them licking the ceiling
that's so creepy
please be a good spirit
yes
suddenly we can't show a lot the giant
thing is uh
nuri what was it nurikave which is like
a fake wall that's supposed to trick
people in their homes trying to
understand but there's no english 25
chance you get the one you want
but mine's from animal crossing so whoa
what is that
refreshing i want to get
the wall
it's not
the gacha guard gods are not on my side
today
nice
oh it's for the drink okay that's kind
of fun
oh my god
that is hideous
so this yokai
supposed to like
they can get rich they can have families
they could even marry like
humans instead or something like that
some people hate on shaved ice it's so
good on a hot day
it's just what you want anyway it's so
good
i'm refreshed you're cold oh my god you
got goosebumps all right so it's one uh
one o'clock now we're heading back home
it's a nice morning
yeah
that's gonna be my next car
sorry tesla
that was my first
100 kilo price
i'm new with the barbell so
i don't know if it counts
i don't know if i went all the way down
or not you guys tell me if it counts i
have no honestly i don't know
but maybe next week i'll do it better
we kept hearing thunder and we're like
how it's
bright outside
and it's like oh oh i think i just saw a
lightning
it's coming
maya's having a good day
it's nine and she's not crazy she's just
a little crazy
right maya
worked out
in my japanese had a great day that was
wonderful